are you hoping that people take away
from the film because a lot of people
will have read the book as well yeah
yeah I'm hoping they just enjoy looking
at beany like she's in every single
scene and she's so joyous and just to
see a girl who looks like that acting in
the way that she does like kind when she
has her makeover and she's got the red
hair and the top hat and she's strutting
down the street I'm just like you know
it's nice to have a girl that you can
pretend to be when you're feeling a bit
insecure and I now pretend that I'm
beanie doing that so yeah new dreams for
girls to have about who they could be in
the future and also just to laugh I mean
to be honest I would be happy if it was
not in any way seen as like a dramatic
cess or a cultural success so long as
people have just laughed when they're
watching it because you just cannot
laugh too much in this world great thing
about it being semi-autobiographical is
that the character that is based on me
is being played by Benny Feldstein he
will like clearly go on to win Oscars
and be the rule of the universe so like
it's like I get to relive my life with
someone much cooler this stuff which
somehow makes it like I did it on
purpose
which you didn't really feel like at the
time so no it's a brilliant vindication
and so much of our teas either you
either do because you fancy someone you
want to show off to them or because you
want revenge on someone who chased you
across some wastelands while shedding
you fat Gruffalo
I very much come from the second camp so
finally having the the movie on screen
with someone so beautiful and brilliant
playing me it just means that finally
the demons of all those boys that call
me a [ __ ] Ruffalo have been crushed
it's got to be film friendly when it was
working out what the key thing was
everyone to say like what is the key
story in this because there's so many
bits in the book and I realized that
when I was 16 I became a journalist and
I was probably the only girl in the
country at that time that had a national
platform to write about what I thought
and how I saw the world and the culture
at the newspaper that I was at was that
you were horrible to patency you just
became a [ __ ] and you destroyed bands
and that was how you became top dog so I
did that for a while and then I realized
that that was horrible I was upsetting
people people who just wanted to make
music like why are you having a go at
people who want to make songs and and so
and that's the story that you're Hannah
goes on in the movie if going from like
being a [ __ ] and becoming famous
because of it to going no we shouldn't
be like this we should be joyful and of
course now every sixteen-year-old in the
world can have a national platform
because we're all on social media and
that tends to be our story we go and
social media
thoughtful cheerful and friendly right
about things we like someone as a go at
you someone trolls you and slowly you
become more cynical and suddenly then
you're the snark you want having a go at
stuff and the thing about becoming
cynical particularly when you're young
putting on that armor of cynicism and
slagging everything off is at the
beginning you do it to protect yourself
because you want to look older and kind
of like more I favor the world but
gradually it becomes constricting it
traps you you can't grow when you're in
armor you know you can't dance when
you're in armor and see everybody goes
through the same journey in the end you
go no I need to be positive it learns to
be about joy I'm not gonna waste my time
being horrible I'm gonna find the good
things and point at them instead I'm
constantly astonished that there hasn't
been arrival to Twitter invented where
no one can be anonymous everybody has to
be registered all you'd have to do is
have like the ten most famous
Kardashians out of the thousand
Kardashian's going we've invented this
new platform
no one's anonymous the motto is be kind
we're all going there now we've all
posted a picture of our bums bang ten
billion people would immediately go to
that new platform and Twitter would be
out of business
so if I ever meet the Kardashians after
we've all done pictures of our bums
together that would be what under posing
for 10% of the profits yeah well I mean
just globally I mean five hundred years
ago we were being burnt as witches 120
years ago we couldn't vote we couldn't
own property you know with the black
jobs that we could have were limited so
every day is better than the previous
one this is why I think again when you
look at female art it tends not to be
nostalgic it's always about the present
or the future because again if you're
from any minority you don't want to
dwell on the past because that's when
you were being burnt or that's when you
were a slave or that's when you were
being oppressed so it's all going to be
about now or the future and that means
for a wide audience that's more exciting
because I think we just had enough of
history and enough of nostalgia show me
new women and culture leads you know
very political we need to vote we need
laws that will protect us and that we
you know he go to the arbitration and
tribunals and stuff but culture has an
equal power because it changes things so
quickly and in art you can invent future
kinds of women that then you watch is a
teenage girl going although that's what
women must be like and it's not it's
girls like me who were scared teenagers
who weren't that sassy and didn't have
the big comeback
I've got to 44 I can now write a teenage
girl who is sassy and does have a
comeback and then my teenage girls are
watching that going oh that's what
teenage girls are like so that's
I'm gonna be then that's why that
feminists saying I cannot be what I
cannot see is the most important thing
and that's for me the driving thing in
art create the things that we want to be
let's invent futures let's invent new
kinds of girls because you make the
dream a reality